application responsiveness is required
for a good user experience
no matter how nice your ui looks if the
application is slow users are going to
be frustrated many times database
performance is the cause of application
slowdowns slow database queries result
in slow application requests
cloud spanner recently launched query
insights to assist users in diagnosing
performance issues with their queries
let me show you how easy it is to use
query insights to help diagnose query
performance issues in spanner
[Music]
imagine that you get an alert in the
middle of the night your database is
using too much cpu
now you need to find out why
if you've worked with databases long you
know how much of a pain it can be to
pinpoint the root cause of database
slowdowns
but if you start your performance
investigation looking for problematic
queries you're going to be faster
resolving the issue
this is why we've developed query
insights
query insights is a set of pre-built
dashboards which makes it very easy to
visualize spikes in query performance
so developers and dbas alike can easily
drill down to the problematic query or
queries
as a spanner user let's say you get that
alert about high cpu
the alert will link you to the
monitoring chart and sure enough your
spanner instance is using an unusually
high amount of cpu
this confirms that there could be
inefficient queries running during that
time window
now you click into query insights
here you find both the cpu usage and the
top queries consuming that cpu in that
time window
the top queries help you identify the
problematic query or queries
there's some other information about the
queries as well
for example how many times that query
shape was executed
maybe a single slow query caused that
spike in cpu or maybe hundreds of
executions of a faster query caused it
either way now you can drill down and
point to exactly which query or queries
could be causing the issue
then you can click into the queries and
analyze them to find out more
information such as how many rows were
scanned versus returned or the latency
of requests
in my case i found an expensive query
that gets a random set of 100 rows from
the players table
i can now refactor how this is handled
to improve the performance of these
requests
now whether you found a slow query that
needs to be rewritten
or faster queries that might need to be
cached so you don't make the requests as
often query insights helped you get to
this point quickly
making sure your database is performing
well is critical to the success of your
application
cloud spanner query insights was
developed to help you find a poorly
performing queries quickly
and the best part is you don't need to
do anything to start using query
insights it's enabled by default
it is worth noting that only queries and
dml are supported by query insights
this means that requests made using
spanner mutations are not available
if you are using queries in dml for your
application workload on cloud spanner go
ahead
check out query insights to find out
which queries might be slowing down your
database
[Music]